I'll er is with us in Oklahoma hi Tyler
how are you hey Dave I'm well I'm
originally from Columbia Tennessee and a
longtime listener all the way back to
90s wow thanks for caring about people
and our financial health well thank you
sir how can we help well I'm a leadoff
oil worker Dave and thanks for your
teachings I am debt free and I'm able to
navigate this downturn my question Dave
is a the fiscal conservative I'm a
little bit concerned and with the money
supply increasing by three trillion in
one year the printing press is turning
and the Federal Reserve is manipulating
markets right and buying junk bonds and
we got double-digit unemployment and we
have a president who is calling for
negative rates and who politics aside is
objectively a fan of debt bankruptcy so
with that said my question to you sir is
where do you see inflation going if they
continue to this printing and what do
you say to people like Ray Dalio who say
gold should occupy a place in the
portfolio as a hedge against inflation
that's my question well you've been
listening to me for a while so you know
I'm not gonna tell you to buy gold yes
that you knew that for you called and I
don't you know I don't know Ray and I
don't know what his teachings are but I
don't buy gold and I don't recommend
people buy gold and we can talk through
why let's pretend for a second that
hyperinflation occurred okay that your
worst fears with your scenario occur
okay and we go back to the Carter
Administration and we had ten and twelve
percent inflation a year which we
haven't really seen since then but let's
say that that happens due to the
oversupply of money and this trillion
dollar three trillion dollar bailouts
and that's what you're worried about and
I agree with you that is what they've
been doing if there's unwise for sure I
don't think it's gonna take it's the
same place you think it's gonna take us
to but let's just pretend it did that it
takes into a real heavy inflation rate
there is no promise that gold follows
that on an inverse relationship meaning
there is no promise that the value of
gold goes up as the value of the dollar
goes down because they are not tied
together in
anyway there is no index we do not
operate on the gold standard anymore and
so gold goes up like all commodities oil
gold silver agricultural products like
wheat these are all and they go up based
on I perceived shortage or a procedure
they go down based on a perceived
oversupply when there is a shortage of
gold is when people are greedy and they
think that they're going to make a bunch
of money on gold so they rush gold or
anything else and when there is a or
when they're afraid and so like during
coronavirus go went up stock market went
down people are afraid because they have
an emotional attachment to gold they
don't have to the other commodities that
think that makes them think that gold is
a safe place it is not it's not safe is
a golden colored rock it has no
intrinsic value except to the fact that
two different people are fighting over
it and that's the only thing that gives
it value the same exact thing that gives
a green piece of paper with the
president's face on it value it has no
intrinsic value it's a green piece of
paper the only reason it has value is
that people want it from one another and
will accept it from one another that's
the only thing that gives it value and
so my friend rabbi lapin talks about
money is spiritual in that sense in that
it is based on trust it is not based on
mathematics and and the trust that I can
train a green piece of paper or a bar of
gold or a golden cuff link or something
for something else then that's what
makes it valuable and so in the event
that a world that an economy collapses
we do not automatically rush out with
bars of gold to the quick sack and fill
up our car they don't it's not how it
works
the first thing that happens in a
completely collapsed economy is it
returns to a barter economy and I can
show you examples of that
take for instance New Orleans after
Katrina that is a microcosm a small
economy
it completely collapsed and there was a
period of weeks that you really couldn't
trade a bar of gold for anything but a
pair of blue jeans or a can of gasoline
you could trade or bottled water you
could trade for almost anything and it
became just basically a barter
oftentimes a black-market barter economy
and that's the first thing that happens
when an economy collapses people don't
return to gold they don't go to their
safe and get out diamonds they go to
their safe and get out bullets that's
what happens and so think through the
reality of that and then from there some
other organization comes to power and
new government is formed and then a new
form of currency occurs for instance I
have on my shelf a green beret brought
me back a handful of paper money with a
picture on it of Saddam Hussein the
former government of Iraq and obviously
that paper money has zero value except
as a souvenir
no one will accept it in exchange for
something else and they never went to
the gold standard in Iraq they went to
black market butter economy after they
were overthrown until a new government
went into place which guess what printed
up new colored paper money that's what
they did so I don't buy gold it has a
crummy track record as an investment